je me suis marié je me suis marié je me
suis marié vite mais je me suis mariée
jeune si je me suis mariée à l'âge de 26
ans à 26 ans paris ces jeunes parce
qu'en utilisant paris tu commences
l'adolescence tu connais pas trop la vie
et vous tu connais et moi je suis pas de
panique je suis d'alsace là bas ça notre
tenir autre dimension là bas tous les
mecs de mon âge ils sont tous déjà
mariés ils ont tous déjà des enfants qui
ont presque mon âge je sais pas quand
ils ont des soins dont elle est bien la
vérité moi je n'ai pas de strasbourg
strasbourg c'est la ville la plus connue
là-bas thonon connais moi je viens d'une
petite ville au sud de strasbourg qui
s'appelle de sélestat c'est une ville de
[Musique]
senneville de 20000 habitants environ si
un jour vous avez l'occasion d'aller
là-bas louper cette occasion voit la
photo
non sans prétention aucune sans
prétention aucune je pense avoir eu une
des pires en france du monde
je m'explique j'ai grandi dans une cité
à la campagne
mais je répète vous êtes à capter
dans une cité à la campagne c'est à dire
moi je peux pas dire comme tout le monde
je galérais dans la rue j'ai galéré dans
la stricte moi j'ai galéré dans la forêt
où la faune des cours chez moi des
cailleras elle péché s'était dépêché au
reggae ras jdir